How about data transfer. Well once again,
when you think about full virtualization, data transfer
is implicit. Any data movement that has to
happen between they hypovisor and the fully virtualized
outputting system happens implicitly. In a para
virtual setting, for example in xen, there's an
opportunity again, to innovate because you can be
explicit about the data movement from the guest
operating system into the hypervisor, and vice-versa. There
are two aspects to resource management and accountability
,when it comes to data transfer. The first
is, the CPU time. So when ,an interrupt
comes in, for instance, from a device, hypervisor
has to demultiplex the data That is coming
from the device to the domains very quickly
upon an interrupt. And that is CPU time involved,
in making such copies. And, the hypervisor
has to account for the computation time from
managing the buffers on behalf of the virtualized
operating system above it. The CPU time accountability
is crucial from the point of your
billing and data centers, and therefore hypervisors pay
a lot of attention to, how CPU time
is accounted for and charged to the appropriate
virtual machines. The second aspect of a data transfer
is how the memory buffers are managed. There is
a space issue. The first is a time issue.
CPU time issue. The second is a space issue. Meaning,
how are the memory buffers allocated? And how are
they managed, either by the guest operating system or
by the hypovisor? As I said in the context,
the full virtualization that is available to scope for innovation.
But in the context of paravirtualization, there's
a lot of scope for innovation in the
way memory buffers are handled. Between the
guest operating system and the hypervisor. Specifically, looking
at Xen as an instance of para
virtualization, let's look at the opportunities for innovation
in the guest OS to Xen communication.
Xen provides asynchronous IO rings, which is basically
a data structure that is shared Between
the guest and the Xen for communication. Any
number of these, data structures, that is any number of these I/O rings can be
allocated for handling all the device I/O
needs of a particular guest domain. The I/O
ring itself. Is just a set of
descriptors. What you see here, they're all descriptors
that are available in this data structure. And
it's a ring data structure, that's why it's
called IO ring. And we'll talk about how it is used in a minute. The idea
is, requests from the guest can be placed
in this IO ring by populating these descriptors.
Every descriptor is a unique I/O request coming
from the guest operating system. So every request,
is going to have a unique ID associated with
that particular request coming from the guest operating
system. And recall, what I said earlier that is the I/O ring is specific to a
guest. So every guest can declare a set of I/O rings As data structures for its
communication with xen. Now, in responding to the
request from the guest, xen, after it completes
processing the request, it'll place a response back in the same I/O ring in one
of these descriptors, and that. This pointer's going to
have the same unique ID that was used
to communicate the request in the first place.
So ,it's sort of a symmetric relationship between
the guest and Xen, in terms of request
and response for things that the guest wants
Xen to get done on its behalf. And for Xen to communicate back ,to the guest
that has completed what was requested of them.
So the guest is the producer of requests.
So it has a pointer, into this data structure that says ,where it has to place
the next request. So, this is a pointer
that is manipulated, meaning modified, by the guest.
But it is readable by Xen. So there's only
one guy that can modify, that is a guest. But
Xen can look at this pointer. It's a shared pointer
in that sense. For example, the guest operating system may
have placed new requests, and that's why it has
moved it's pointer to here, indicating that it has placed
new requests. This is the next empty spot, where it
can place new requests, after these two requests. The consumer
for the request produced by the guest operating
system, is of course Xen. And it is
processing requests in the order in which, they've
been produced by the guest operating system. And
therefore, it has the pointer into this IO
ring data structure, saying Where exactly it is
presently servicing requests from this guest operating system.
So right now ,the pointer is pointing here indicating
that Xen is yet to process these two requests that have been queued by the
producer. Meaning, the guest operating system, into this
I/O ring data structure. So this pointer that
the request consumer has is private to Xen. It is just telling Xen ,where it is
in processing requests from the producer. And the
difference between these two pointers is telling how
many requests are outstanding so far as
Xen is concerned, in terms of processing. Request
emanating from the guest. Similar to request production,
Xen is going to be the guy that is
offering responses back to the guest operating system.
So Xen, is the response producer. So it's
going to have a pointer, where it can place
new responses. So once again, this pointer is
a shared pointer updated by Xen, but can be read by the guest. So these are two
new responses that Xen has placed in the I/O Ring in response to request
that it has already processed, but these
responses have not yet been picked up. By
the producer. The guest operating system has a
pointer that says where it is in this
I/O ring data structure, in terms of picking
up the responses coming from Xen. Xen has produced
these two new responses as a result of
processing some prior requests. From the guest operating system,
but the guest operating system is yet to
process this request. So, this pointer is private to
the guest operating system that is telling it, where
it is in processing responses coming back from Xen.
The difference between this pointer and this pointer
is the number of Responses that are yet to
be picked-up by the guest operating system. Just to
recap, the difference between these two pointers is the
number of requests that are yet to be processed
by Xen. And the difference between these two pointers
is the number of responses that are yet to
be picked-up by the guest. And these slots ,are
the empty slots. Into which ,new requests
can be placed by the request producers. The
request producer moves like this. And the
response ,taker moves like this. And, the response
producer moves like this. And the request
consumer moves like this. And these are the
empty slots into which. Xen can place additional
responses as it processes more requests from the
guest operating system. That's the idea behind this higher ring data structure.
Very powerful extraction that allows the
guest to place requests [UNKNOWN], and for
Xen to place responses [UNKNOWN], into
the data structure. As I mentioned already,
the guests can identify the request for which a particular response is intended,
because the id that is associated. With the
response is going to be exactly the same, as
the ID that was associated with the request in
the first place. The other thing that, we should
remember is that these are just descriptors of
the requests and responses. Any data, that has to
be passed from the guest to Xen will just
be a pointer from these descriptors to a machine
page that the guest owns, so that Xen can pick up the data directly, from
that machine page without any copy. Similarly,
if the responses given by Xen is going to
have data associated with it, that will
again be A pointer from the descriptive data
structure to the machine page that contains the
data that Xen wants to pass up to
the guest. In other words, this asynchronous I/O rings is a powerful mechanism,
both for efficient communication between the guest and Xen. And for
also, avoiding. Copying overhead between the
para-virtualized guest operating system and Xen,
which is the virtualization layer. We will look at two specific examples,
on how these I/O rings are used for guest and Xen communication.